periodic well it means for a given time
period okay in this case time is like
our x-value do the y-values repeat okay
so just because there's a pattern
doesn't mean that it's a periodic
pattern meaning that it's cycling
through and repeating that same y-value
for a multiple of the x-value so in this
case it is periodic so we're gonna say
yes for this one what is the period well
that's saying how long does it take you
know what's the time period for it to
repeat and start over
well you can see this is going every two
it's going up and then down
okay next two up and then down so we can
see the period is two it's repeating
every two okay every time the x
increases by two now the next few
questions relate to the output for a
given input so when X is two what's the
Y value what's the output well you can
see when X is 2 the Y value is 0 when X
is 23 what's the output well we don't
want to necessarily draw this graph all
the way out to 23 but if we realize that
you know repeats every two let's see how
many times does 2 go into 23 well it's
11 times remainder one so it's like
going up and down up and down 11 times
and then on that 23rd one you're going
right 1 and you can see the out Val
output value is 1 now the last one F of
negative 23 we're going to the left to
the negative Direction 23 units again
same pattern up and down up and down
repeating every 2 right again 2 goes
into 23 11 times so on that 23rd step to
the left the graph is going to be going
up here and the Y value is going to be 1
so you're with me so far on that first
example so we're trying to figure out is
it periodic and what is the period and
then what's that Y value or what's that
output for a given x value so example
number 2 now you can see the stare like
pattern this step like graph ok and the
question is is it periodic well some
students might say yes but the thing is
is that even though there's a pattern
you know you can see that every time you
go one to the right it's stepping up one
that pattern does not repeat meaning
like if I go up till let's see 1 2 3 4
does it start over again then
one two three four one two three four is
it repeating no it's not so this one is
actually not periodic we'll just put no
for that one and the period is just you
know not applicable right na but we can
still calculate what these function
values are so when X is 3 okay 1 2 3 we
go up to the graph what's the Y value
you can see the Y value is 3 what's F of
2 well you can see it's 2 what's F of 1
it's 1 so what do you think F of 63
would be well it's going to be 63 so
this one was not periodic but we could
still calculate what those values are by
noticing the pattern it's just not a
repeating pattern so it's not periodic
so we're gonna go through one more
example but before I do that I just want
to mention that if you're preparing for
the AC T or the SAT check out my huge AC
T math review video course and my huge
SAT math review video course we go
through a number of different topics
that are covered on those important
tests formulas example problems things
that you would expect to see so that
you're prepared when you go into those
tests so if you like my teaching style
check out some of the previews that are
available for you to check out see if
that's a right fit for you and go ahead
and get those courses but let's get into
example number 3 this one what do you
think is it periodic does that pattern
repeat well let's take a look so for
starting here it goes you know like a
plateau and then it kind of goes down
and then it plateaus and then it goes up
and then it plateaus and it looks like
yes this pattern is repeating ok so what
that means is that you know every so
many units to the right that pattern
starts over again and then repeats so
this one is periodic so we're going to
say yes for that now the question is
what is the period well let's see so if
we start here we're going to the right
down to the right up off so from here to
here you can see that's one cycle and
then it starts over again so how many
units is that it's 1 2 3 4 5 so you can
see that our period is going to be 5 ok
just verify that that repeats but it
looks like it's 5 units so now this one
F of 1 so when we go x equals 1 1 to the
right we go up to the graph you can see
the Y value is 2 F of 24 hmm well we
know it repeats every 5 so let's see how
many times
five going to 24 well we know four times
right remainder 4 so that means that
we're going to be repeating the cycle
five times alright and then 1 2 3 4 you
can see the y-value is 0 and then the
last one F of negative 20 that means
we're going to the left 20 right so let
me switch sides here so to the left 20
that means we're going 1 2 3 4 5 and
then you can see we're going to be up
here at 2 and then it's same thing it's
going to go 6 7 8 9 10
we're going to be up here at 2 again so
we're gonna repeat that cycle 4 times
then remainder 4 so let's look at that
remainder 4 1 2 3 4
ah you can see we're gonna be right
there at y equals 2 so that's the result
F of negative 20 so I hope this helped
you to understand how to work with
whether or not functions are periodic
how to find the period and how to find
some of the output values when you're
given an input value
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon